La volta al món a peu
Dia 280
Són les 6 i mitja
He passat una bona nit
Ha fet fred a fora, ho notava
Ha fet fred
I de fet estava pensant
Fa massa fred, no?
No hauria de fer tant de fred
He deixat el Garmin
encès tota la nit perquè marqués
la temperatura i sí
La previsió s'ha equivocat
L'aplicació deia que la mínima d'avui
havia de ser al voltant dels 5 graus
I ha sigut de 2
2 graus de mínima
segons el rellotge
Això són males notícies perquè
què vol dir? Que quan les mínimes
marquin a l'aplicació
menys 1 o menys 2 tindrem menys 4
o menys 5
Bueno, no sé
Ja ho veurem
Sí, ha fet mandra aixecar-se
però mira, amb els guants i la jaqueta
ara estic perfecte
i preparat pel que serà
un enorme dia
en tots els sentits
Primer tram del dia d'avui
15 quilòmetres
encara per la Pamir
fins a arribar a un lloc on hi ha un supermercat
i la desviació
cap al sender
o pista
o el que sigui que és
Faré els 15 quilòmetres
els més ràpids que pugui
per poder dedicar més temps
a la resta
Faig ulleres avui
No he dormit del tot bé
A les 4 o així m'he despertat
i després ja m'ha costat dormir
no sé si de nervis o què
Ho he intentat
però re, tu
Bueno
ja em passa de tant en quant
quan passa això
cada cop que parlo
s'han tancat els ulls
Christian, què fas aquí?
Hi ha alguna cosa que no està funcionant
Com pot ser que ho vegi més ràpid que jo?
I que no ens haguem cruzat
una altra vegada ahir
Exactament, no, anoix estava un poc mal de la panxa
i bé, a la tarda
molt tancat, vaig buscar un lloc
i em vaig quedar a descansar
I com estàs?
Ara un poc millor
Tinc alguna medicina?
Tinc, en tomé
i en tomé alguna salada
d'hidratants
com per veure si puc recuperar-me un poc
però bé, ja estem bé
Eres portada del vídeo d'avui
Bé, boníssim, llavors
un salut per a tots
Ara sí que ens desviarem
perquè jo en 15 quilòmetres
me'n vaig a l'esquerra
a un camí de senderisme
i tu segueixes la Pamir
i segueixo la Pamir
Sí, jo crec que avui
uns 60 quilòmetres més
és paulatinament la pujada
crec que arribaré fins a
a prop dels 4.000
3.900
i bé, aguantar una mica el fred
Sí, sí
Sort, sort
Sort per a vosaltres també
Molt bé
3 hores
16 quilòmetres
he arribat a Berxès
última ciutat
abans d'emprendre
aquesta ruta que us he dit
i
sí, sí, sí
hi ha un cafè
algú el maps no el marcava
però el mapi sí
cafè
ostres, pues me'n ve genial
perquè ara fa més d'un dia
que no menjo
no, ahir, ahir al matí
perfecte, no, però per
per menjar
bé
escolta
me'n quedaré una bona estona
perquè he de carregar la bateria
que la tinc gairebé al zero
i la necessito plena pels propers dies
les 11 i 37
cinquena parada d'autobús ja
bé, m'he quedat més estona
de la prevista
per dir quan he entrat al cafè aquest
l'electricitat no els hi funcionava
i jo buà tio
si aquest és el moment que
almenys necessito l'electricitat
de tot el viatge potser
perquè ara estaré
jo que sé quan sense poder tornar a connectar saps
dic buà, buà, buà
no sé, no sé què faré
per cert
Pamir Highway
la deixo
ara, en aquest moment
bé, dic bueno, doncs no sé
ja en aquest poble
ara ve algun poble
doncs ja trobaré alguna casa que em deixi connectar
i he començat a esmorzar
dos trossos de pollastre fregit
ous
cafè
i el pa no l'he tocat perquè era de
no era d'ahir
era del segle passat aquest pa
després he sortit de compres
i en un market que hi havia
allà sí que tenien electricitat
llavors he pogut carregar
per això m'he quedat més estona
no?
bueno, doncs una hora i mitja o així, no?
una hora i vint
però sí, sí, he carregat fins al 95%
que està perfecte
què més?
m'he gastat un pastó
un pastó, suposo que aquest lloc
clar, al ser així remot
i deu ser difícil arribar
i bueno, es deuen aprofitar una mica els turistes
els camioners
doncs m'he gastat 20 euros, tu
20 euros entre l'esmorzar aquest
i la compra que he fet
que a veure, que està bé, eh?
només dic que
en comparació amb altres llocs de Tadjikistan
és una mica més car
he comprat massa penjar, potser?
clar, és que no sé molt bé
si aquest tram que faré ara
el dividiré en dos o tres dies
s'ha de veure
llavors he agafat menjar de sobre
jo crec que hauria d'estar bé
veieu que la jaqueta, la genovesa 2
o la Tadjika
està per fora?
clar, és que per dintre tinc massa ple
bueno, tu, doncs res
la incògnita d'avui
és com serà el terreny
si és una pista així
puc avançar bastants quilòmetres
perquè es camina bé
si és una típica cosa
que has d'anar pujant
i baixant molt
o la pista no està molt bé
doncs podré avançar menys
llavors potser hauré de dividir
en tres dies, no?
ja ho veurem
en qualsevol cas
anem cap allà
a veure com és això
L'inici de l'Espanya
amb l'acadèmia de la Ducatia
és l'Espanya
La comiseta d'Espanya
que es va centrar
en la política
l'ecologió
l'agricultor
i la ciència
i el racisme
es converteixen
a l'escola
en quals menys
hi ha de funciona
Fins demà!
Les dues i vint-i-quatre, sis hores de marxa i trenta quilòmetres.
Doncs sí, al final, de moment,
aquest tram es camina molt bé
perquè aquesta pista porta fins a un poble,
molt petit poble, que es diu Batxor.
Llavors, bueno, doncs està ben acondicionada.
No m'he trobat absolutament a ningú,
però sí que hi ha algunes roderes de cotxe,
suposo 4x4.
Serà a partir de Batxor
quan ja veurem, potser es complica.
Bueno, vaig a bastant bon ritme.
Ara feia temps que no...
M'exigia de càrdio
perquè caminant per carretera
al final vas, tires molt
de múscul més que de càrdio.
Però bueno, com
no fa gaire calor i l'aire que passa és fred,
això em pot fer
aguantar el rendiment i sí, sí, vaig a 5 km per hora.
Pararé
en algun moment, sí, sí.
Però de moment encara no.
De moment segueixo, tu.
Molt bé, a més, el paisatge guapíssim, eh?
Les 4 de la tarda, ja he arribat a Batxor.
Mireu quin pont, tu.
Buà.
Mira, mira, ja que cada vaca, eh?
Per aquí han passat vaques, tu.
Tremola, eh?
Tremola, però...
però sembla segur.
M'encanta aquest riu
amb aquesta aigua turquesa, eh?
Allà n'hi ha una altra.
Ara descansaré per aquí,
d'acord? Per aquesta zona
i després creuaré l'altre pont
per seguir.
Està tort, eh?
Hi ha uns nens aquí?
Sí.
Hi ha gent que m'està aquí.
Buà.
Aquest pont
el veig bastant
més precari, eh?
Anem a creuar-lo,
a veure.
Buà.
Buà, ostres.
Crec que no he passat mai un pont
tan xungo, eh?
Vale.
És que no puc ni agafar-me, eh?
M'hauria de xupir, vale?
Buà.
Buà, tremola molt, eh?
Mare de Déu.
Ostres, tu.
Està fet amb...
amb troncs petits, eh?
Buà, a més tenia el riu aquest a sota
que...
que va tan ràpid, impressiona bastant, eh?
Buf. Com es mou, això.
Vinga, passem-ho ràpid, passem-ho ràpid.
Ai, ai, ai, ai, ai.
Vale.
Vale, tio.
Buf.
Pont de la mort.
Bueno.
Ara he fet una estona de descans,
20 minutets, bueno, una mica més.
M'ha vingut un ranger.
Demà passaré
breument pel
Parc Nacional de Tajikistán.
Es diu així, el nom.
El Parc Nacional de Tajikistán és una extensió
enorme de terreny.
Enorme.
Passaré una mica per la banda sud.
I jo havia vist al màpic
que la caseta del guarda
està més endavant.
Però no, no, m'ha enxampat aquí el guarda
i molt simpàticament m'ha fet pagar, sabeu quant?
12 euros.
T'ho trobo molt, no?
12 euros crec que és el segon part
que ens fan pagar.
El primer va ser a Geòrgia, us en recordeu d'aquell home
que em va agafar amb el cotxe,
em va pujar a dalt, després tornar, en fi.
Tot un rotllo.
Doncs, doncs, mireu,
mireu quin prat.
Bueno, tot per res.
Segueixo.
Fins quan?
Doncs m'agradaria apurar a 6.30.
Ja, fer els... crec que no és per aquí, eh?
No ho sé, perquè
estic entrant al jardí d'aquesta casa.
Fins a 6.30 arriba als...
als 9 quilòmetres més
a partir d'ara.
Complicat? No ho sé.
A les 5.30
a poc a poc
se'n va el sol
i ara he de baixar.
He de baixar fins al pont aquell.
Tu diràs, ostres, Enric,
quins ponts més...
més merdosos.
No, no. Sort
que hi ha aquests ponts merdosos, eh?
Perquè si no, hauria de creuar el riu
i no es podria. O sí, sí que es podria,
però...
T'hauries de mullar.
Mullar bastant.
Molt bé.
D'acord. Avui tenia dos opcions.
Bé, tres, realment. Una,
agafar una guescaus
al poble per on acabo de passar,
que de fet un home m'ho ha ofert. M'ha dit,
ei, homestay, homestay.
Espera que no...
La segona opció era
acampar per aquí.
Més o menys per aquesta zona.
Potser aquí baix, al costat del pont
o jo què sé, en algun lloc.
Eh...
I la tercera...
Mira, mira quin vent.
Mira quin vent!
Sort que no havia de fer vent, eh?
Que us ho vaig dir ahir.
Per on és el camí?
No hi ha camí, eh?
Però bueno.
Baixaré per aquí.
Doncs...
Val.
Doncs la tercera opció
és un lloc
que he vist d'aquí a uns
quatre quilòmetres i mig.
És una mica ajustat perquè el sol se'n va
a les 6 i 36.
Una mica ajustat, però bueno.
Eh...
Ho faré.
O ho intentaré, com a mínim.
Perquè així demà...
O sigui, podré fer aquest tram
en dos dies, en comptes de tres,
com us he dit aquest matí.
I això...
és bastant positiu.
Eh...
D'acord.
Vinga, va.
Let's go.
Ah...
Jo no sé si quan venim.
Enhorabona.
I amb la côva.
Està molt estressant.
Va.
Ya lo sé.
Pero ¿qué pasa?
Claro.
No…
Que no está bueno.
Eso es.
Entonces lo intentaré.
Ya lo haré.
Vamos y haremos.
Sí.
Ya lo haré.
Aquí no puedo.
Pues...
Me lo haría.
Bueno, que tal!
Et ha parecido, ¿no?
No me he visto.
Nada.
Hace un mes me ha parecido.
No sé si el tram ha perdido su valor.
Ah!
La mare del Tano.
Primera vegada a la meva vida que veig el que crec que és un llac.
Aquest animal crec que es diu llac.
S'ha espantat més ell que jo.
No us enfoco, però allà veig un altre animal, sembla un cavall.
I allà tampoc ho veureu, però veig més animals, no sé si són vaques o llacs.
Jo tampoc ho sé veure.
Bueno, hem arribat.
No exacte, però és aquesta espècie de zona plana per aquí.
Trobo que està molt bé, excepte els animals.
Que mira, els llacs no crec que facin res, eh?
Perdoneu.
Però els cavalls...
Un cop he tingut problemes amb cavalls.
Bueno, bueno.
Quin dia, eh?
Quin lloc més impressionant.
Llàstima que no hi hagi sol.
Però...
Estic a vista del no-res.
Al mig del no-res, és brutal.
És brutal.
Va, vaig a buscar el lloc de campada.
Fot fred, eh?
Vale.
Hi havia bastants llocs, però he vingut per allà.
I aquí?
Aquí és bastant pla, hi ha una mica de tifes, però estan seques.
Això és bo, també.
Vol dir que no he vingut cap a animar últimament.
Sí, bastantes tifes.
Però bueno, si em poso per aquí, no tantes.
I com veieu, està envoltat d'arbres.
Per tant, està una mica més protegit pel vent.
Quines vistes, eh? Aquestes glaceres aquí.
D'acord, estic dintre la tenda.
Ara mateix amb la càmera de selfie, que normalment no la faig servir mai, però...
Bé, és igual.
48 quilòmetres avui, etapa...
Etapon.
Sí, sí, sí, amb totes les lletres.
I mil i pico, mil i poc.
1.080 de desnivell positiu.
He menjat ja.
Són les vuit i mitja, porto una estona aquí.
He agafat el menjar, l'he posat fora de la tenda penjada d'un arbre.
I avui no he parlat amb ningú.
M'he gastat 32 euros per l'entrada del parc aquest.
I un cafè.
Dos, dos cafès.
Hi ha un silenci sapulcral.
Cosa que està bé.
Però com passa un riarol a prop, a vegades amaga una mica el soroll de quan el vent mou les fulles,
que sempre t'inquieta una mica.
Bé, al final dormo amb els taps i ja està.
Bé, avui serà una nit freda.
Ara mateix estic bé.
Ara mateix no tinc fred.
De fet, tinc la jaqueta oberta perquè si no tinc calor.
És a partir de les 3-4, que normalment la temperatura baixa bastant en picat.
A veure.
Tinc la jaqueta.
Pels pantalons, per les cames, tinc el pantaló de pluja.
Que tu diràs, home, això sua perquè no transpira.
Ja, però si tens fred, t'escalfa.
Després, si hi ha tal, ja t'ho treus, saps?
Però sí.
Pels peus, us en recordeu que a l'hivern vaig portar una espècie de mitjons de plomont?
Ara no els tinc.
Doncs, similar als pantalons, la bossa que vaig servir per inflar el matalàs,
puc posar els peus a dintre.
I sí que és veritat que...
no transpira gaire, encara que té el forat per inflar, però bueno.
No transpira gaire, doncs es nota.
Es nota bastant, ahir vaig provar i bastant de seguida et dóna calor.
Dóna calor.
Després, per les mans tinc els guants i pel cap tinc la caputxa.
Serà la nit més freda de la meva vida?
Demà al matí us ho explicaré.
Demà, dia important perquè arribem al poble més fred de la Unió Soviètica.
Demà us dono més detalls.
Bona nit.